welcome to Metro city a concrete
paradise that hundreds of citizens call
home skyscrapers and multi-story
buildings dominate every block walk
instruction takes place nearby another
towering structure taking shape within
the city limits to begin we're going to
use the helicopter crews to help that
construction get started generator must
make it a construction site or how can
construction begin use the d-pad to
raise and lower the cable when it's down
you can use it to pick up items all
people using the d-pad again will
release them and praise the cable
hey buddy you can help us get that
generator turned on please have someone
interested me and need you to transport
them to the place when you know that
yeah but the news people I'm gonna fly
downtown and see what I can see and then
report it
well what I see is a car wreck bigan -
yes you've got a mess on your hands I
can move those cars and get them to
construction sites where they're out of
the way
Tower I seem to have gotten lost in a
cloud bank or something but you get
directions to make my way to the airport
I'd appreciate it
Tower this Falcon one I have
malfunctioned Rahu targeted me need a
vector to buzz in a pendant so the guns
can take this thing down
we need coordinates for the down pilot
tower I have an engine fire gonna need
some assistance with that get us over
that pilot and we can bring him up in
the book make sure we're selecting you
use the down arrow on the touchpad and
drop the hook they've got too bad the
waters nasty today
I think that's off shark give us a
vector for the independence and we'll
drop
the pilot tower I have more these wonky
drums on my table finally passed the
independence it became
gonna meet someone who's loomed down
here and putting this fire out
something's happening this is vulture
squadron we're on the carry attack ready
for temporary whenever you're ready
Tower
sour I have an engine fire going to need
some assistance with that
the exhaust auto control
use the right trigger to fire missiles
just hold that trigger down while you
stare down a predator to fire
the key
it's our engineers ready to be carried
from the carriers of the independence
give us our pickup coordinates we'd
appreciate more drones
while Foxbat brings us those engineers
maybe you could come along the guns
Tower
I need to get down carrier he could help
me land I'd appreciate
Tower is the carrier who some men
overboard non-swimmers have you could
help us out we need to toss them some
life
nice throw
thank
boo
nice throw
Tower I need a landing Viktor for the
carrier
that's great work tower why don't you
take some R&R you've earned